[Music]
my name is dr sabrina smiley i'm one of
the 2022 program co-chairs
and we are so excited to host this
evening's event
the topic tonight is tobacco regulatory
science health equity mental health and
public engagement
and it's a live podcast by doctor
created by dr knee addy
and we have an expert panel dr pebbles
fagin
mitch zeller and kathleen crosby
i'm going to introduce dr addie and let
him have it
dr nee addie is the alfred e kent
professor of psychiatry and associate
professor of cellular and molecular
physiology
he received his bs in biology from duke
university and his phd in neuroscience
from yale university
dr addie directs a federally funded
research program investigating
cholinergic dopaminergic and l-type
calcium channel mechanisms mediating
substance use and mood disorders
dr abby's team also studies the ability
of tobacco product flavor additives to
alter nicotine use behavior and
addiction
he serves on the journal editorial board
of neuropsychopharmacology
biological psychiatry nicotine and
tobacco research and neuropharmacology
and is a grant reviewer for the
neurobiology of motivated behavior study
section of the national institutes of
health center for scientific review
dr abby currently serves as the
inaugural director of scientist
diversity and inclusion at the yale
school of medicine
as the director of the faculty mentoring
program for the yale minority
organization for retention and expansion
also known as moore
and is co-chair of the career
development subcommittee of the
anti-racism task force in the yale
department of psychiatry
he also contributes to graduate student
in post-doctoral training and to
diversity equity
and inclusion initiatives through his
efforts on campus and in scientific
societies so without further ado please
welcome dr abby
thank you very much for that
introduction it's always humbling to
hear and every time i hear it i always
have to emphasize all the teams that are
actually in place to help us do this
work so i know that's been a theme of
the conference for all those of you who
are here in the room
but i'm really grateful to be able to
have this opportunity to have our first
in-person recording of the addie hour
podcast um there's definitely a
different level of energy that just
comes from being in the room i'm sure
our listeners will be listening across
platforms will sense that as well
so in the spirit of where we are in time
i just want to open up and kind of set
the tone to say as others have said you
know this is a time where we're
definitely
celebrating a lot of things being able
to move and engage in ways that we
haven't done for quite a while as a
society um being able to celebrate a lot
of the work that's being done around
tobacco regulatory science as we'll talk
about today but at the same time we know
there's still a lot that has to be done
um and so i think it's entirely
appropriate and possible for us to hold
both of those things together as we
continue to move forward
as a society and i think what we'll be
talking about today also reflects what's
going on in society as la at large
obviously there's a lot of challenges
going on in the world today even as we
think about everything that's happening
in ukraine and elsewhere i also did want
to acknowledge that this is march 16th
2022 when we're recording and so this is
the one year anniversary of the tragic
events that happened in atlanta a year
ago when several lives were tragically
lost from our asian asian american
pacific islander community so i want to
make sure that we at least acknowledge
that and continue to give space for that
and not forget about those things
because even though that was one
isolated incident there are other things
that continue to happen to members of
that community we want to make sure that
we continue to elevate those
conversations and to move things forward
to action
and of course that action is something i
think that can give us hope as we
continue to try and move forward as a
society even with all the other things
that we've been moving forward some of
those things which you'll hear about
today as well
so with that framing and that uh
approach in a sense i'm really grateful
and honored to be able to be here and to
host this conversation with all of our
esteemed guests and want to go ahead and
introduce them to you now
so as was mentioned already the topic
for today's discussion will be tobacco
regulatory science health equity mental
health and public engagement and so i'm
honored to be able to host individuals
who have been at the forefront of those
types of efforts over the years and
excited to also have them interact with
each other
and to to
see how we can even elevate that
conversation and continue to move things
forward
so i think what i will do is actually
just introduce in the order that we have
of everyone sitting here on the stage
so the first guest which i would like to
introduce which is someone who's
familiar to those of you who are here in
person is mitch zeller who is the
director of the center for tobacco
products and in that role he leads fda's
efforts to reduce disease and death from
tobacco use and bring previously
unavailable information about its
dangers to light
mitch has been in this role at the fda
since march of 2013 and in that role he
has been implementing
the mission of the center for tobacco
products to make tobacco-related death
and disease part of america's past and
not america's future and by doing so to
ensure a healthier life for every
american family
mitch is someone who has been at the
forefront and working at fda-related
issues for more than 30 years he
actually began his career as a public
interest attorney in 1982 at the center
for science in the public interest
in 1993 he actually joined the fda under
then commissioner dr david kessler and
what was supposed to be a two-work
assignment actually turned into a much
longer uh foray with the country so with
the with the fda so to speak or he be
ser where he was serving as an associate
commissioner and director of the fda's
first office of tobacco programs yeah
she left the fda in 2000 to continue to
work in this space with the american
legacy foundation also had a stint as
senior vice president of pioneer
associates and then again returned to
fda in 2013.
as many of you know will be retiring
soon so this has been in some ways a
celebration of his efforts and i'm
honored and grateful to be able to
welcome mitch seller thank you
and seated next to mitch is dr pebbles
fagin who has lots of different titles
i'm only going to highlight a few of
them here just for the sake of time
dr fagan is a professor and the director
of the center for the study of tobacco
in the fade w bozeman college of public
health she is also the director of
research in the office of health
initiatives and disparities research at
the college of medicine college of
medicine at the university of arkansas
and she's someone who has been engaged
in this work for over 25 years
conducting research that seeks to
understand factors associated with
tobacco use and exposure in racial and
ethnic women low socioeconomic status
and youth young adult populations
and she also seeks to develop community
interventions that aim to reduce tobacco
and cancer related disparities dr fagan
has a number of leadership roles and
initiatives one i'll mention is the
newly funded center for research health
and social justice
she also is a senior advisor to the cdc
and also has put a lot of time and
investment training students and faculty
members to advance their research
careers as well
again several different accolades one i
will mention so those of you in the room
have heard this those listening i also
want to make sure that you know that she
just received the presidential award
from the society for research on
nicotine tobacco for her career
contributions to tobacco and disparities
research so honored to welcome dr
pebbles fagin to the attire
and last but definitely not least also
would like to introduce kathleen crosby
who is currently the director of the
office of health communication and
education at the fda center for tobacco
products
so in that role she leads an office that
is responsible for conducting public
education stakeholder outreach and
regulatory communication programs
designed to ensure fda's success in
implementing the tobacco control act
these efforts include developing
breakthrough communication strategies to
reduce youth tobacco use helping current
tobacco users quit and building
stakeholder understanding of compliance
and fda product regulations she's been
involved in multiple public education
campaigns including the real cost
and she also has a long-standing career
with over 20 years of experience as a
senior in senior level marketing and
advertising and working on several
large-scale multimedia campaigns also
served at the ad counselor for quite a
while and was a campaign the campaign
director for 17 united states government
agencies someone who's been very
invested in this realm for quite some
time i'm glad to be able to work on her
here to the podcast as well
well enough of me speaking we obviously
have folks who have lots of accolades
and are experts in their spheres of
influence but for those who may be
regular listeners you know that i always
like to start out just checking in and
seeing how everyone's doing at this
moment in time so i'm going to go in
reverse order now and actually start
with kathy first just to see how you're
doing at this point in time as we
continue to re-engage in society so to
speak
thank you that's a great question i
think
i mean obviously these last several
years have been really difficult
difficult as individuals as a mom as a
wife
certainly as a colleague as a co-worker
but i feel a sense of hope that we're
coming out of it and
i know that more still has to be done
and we you know sometimes i even though
my role is to really pay attention to
the news sometimes i can't look at the
news because you know there seems to be
a big bump coming in
uh covid in europe and so but you know
my my mindset is that it's it's gonna be
okay and we're coming out of it and um
you know i'm excited to collaborate
again in in a in a shared space this
feels so good i've missed that greatly
i've missed the the the collegialness
and the um collaboration and the
creativity that sparked when people come
together so i'm especially thankful that
we're here today yes definitely agree
with you on that and all the aspects
you've highlighted about the hope that
we still have in the midst of everything
thanks so much for sharing honestly
dr fagan what about you
yeah i'm excited about being here after
uh being at the meeting in new orleans
and the few of us who were there and
then coming back here to baltimore is
just amazing
you know these last two years have been
a whirlwind i think for many of us
and uh but i think you know we can talk
about all of the uh
negative things that covet has brought
into our lives but i you know there's
some opportunities that it's brought for
us as well
opportunities for new discoveries
opportunities for
how we relate to each other
and how we treat each other
and opportunities for change
and so those are the things that i've
been focusing on
throughout the pandemic and looking for
new ways to live life how we do our
research and how we tackle
tobacco prevention and control
thanks so much for sharing that not to
jump too far ahead but i love the way
you highlight that because i get the
sense that all of you have been doing
that in your efforts over the years and
are continuing to do that even in this
phase that we've been in over the last
couple of years and moving forward just
using those opportunities to really move
things forward as is needed
mitch what about you
um
it has been great to to be with a bunch
of human beings in person
um i said it when i took the podium
yesterday afternoon
there's going to be some
uh
emerging definition of what the new
normal is
for all of us personally and
professional we don't know what that is
yet i think we all
personally professionally need to expect
the unexpected whether it's the next
surge coming from the other side of the
pond or
other other global issues
and
for me
just on the professional side
uh it's been an extraordinary test
of the
the the people of the center for tobacco
products at fda
and i am grateful for
um
the level of effort during unprecedented
times it has come at a price though for
all of us not just those of us
in federal service i mean the
the challenge of work-life balance
especially if
your family situation involves child
care or elder care or or any other
health related issues
has
we've paid a price
but it's been
very gratifying to see
the commitment and the dedication of the
the people that i
work with as we all kind of mud have
muddled through this
from our home offices or wherever we're
working from
uh at home
to to get the job done and i know that
that goes for everybody involved in
uh tobacco control and and and that that
that to me is what so um
was the emotional reaction i had to be
to be here yesterday
because uh we all have day jobs in
different realms different sectors we're
all working towards the same overarching
public health goal when it comes to
tobacco use and to be back together with
the
uh the wonderful family of the society
for research on nicotine and tobacco
meant a lot to me personally and
professionally that's great thanks so
much for sharing that
really well said and already i know
we're only a few minutes in but so many
themes there
that are
cutting across all the comments that you
all have made one thing that really
strikes me about the work that you do is
it's so focused on people and on society
but then again at some level it seems
that the level of humanity has actually
been increased over the last couple of
years as you're even talking about being
attentive to the different challenges
that people have been walking through
pebbles as you're talking about looking
for new opportunities and and kathy as
you're talking about hope so i wondered
if you all would just actually comment
on that a little bit
in the sense that how has that humanity
been elevated in ways
that it wasn't there before because
again it's something you all were
focused on before but i get a sense that
there's a different level at which that
has
has come across recently so anyone who
wants to to jump out i'll i'll start i
think that um
with the
systemic issues related to
social justice and inequities that
have always been there but
coincidentally emerged during the last
couple of years at a societal level i i
sense all of these these things coming
together because those kinds of systemic
issues
have a direct connection to reducing the
death and disease from tobacco use
because when we look at especially when
we're talking about the most harmful
products any name your combustible
product
who is the remaining smoker
who have we left behind at a population
level with all the progress that has
been made in the last half century in
reducing consumption and prevalence and
there's a direct connection between
all of the profound issues
relating to inequality in this country
and the health issue that we work on so
i've seen more of an intersection
between all of that
unfortunately because of tragedies that
have taken place
in some of our cities over the last
couple years but but from that
just to look at it through the public
health lens is an opportunity because
um
the issue of health equity and health
disparity in in our field at least has
never been more top of mind and more
prominent
because of what's going on in society at
least in my experience in tobacco
control than i've seen in the last two
years and while there's huge
underlying systemic problems that go
beyond reducing the death and disease
from tobacco use i can tell you in this
administration in the federal government
um the the issue of health equity and
health disparity is an enormous priority
and from that
comes this huge public health
opportunity for all of us
when we think about who the remaining
smoker is
yeah and when you think about humanity i
mean of course covet has forced us and
not just covet but all of the social
injustices that have happened over the
last
several years have forced us to think
about you know what does it mean to have
a humane society
and
you know we have used the social
ecological model for many many years to
understand the
multiple influences on human behaviors
and human development
and but have done very little on how we
intervene on those factors beyond the
individual level and so
it has certainly forced me to think more
about that i've always thought about
that
and i can remember when i was at the
national cancer institute and i asked
the question
why don't we
do interventions that intervene on
social factors i always tell nih doesn't
do that right
and but why don't we when the fact is
that
you know the
people who are left behind in terms of
smoking are people who are poor
people who may have low literacy
people who are isil geographically
isolated in rural communities people who
may live in segregated neighborhoods who
may be racialized and so when you think
about those things where tobacco use is
still clustered
and people are left behind
you have to begin to think about the
social circumstances
and the structural factors and how do we
shift and change those things and
we started
integrating those things into
a randomized trial that i was doing
because
our smokers in our study were hungry
i mean they were suffering from food
insecurity
and we had to address that issue
you know we could not just sit there and
try to
do motivational counseling and help
people to keep their homes smoke free
and quit
when they were suffering from food
insecurity issues and so we had to begin
to address that partnering the food bank
and getting food out to the communities
that's what we had to do
you know really well said and really
important before catherine furry jumped
to you uh dr fake i also just wanted to
and you start to allude to this already
as someone who's been doing this work
for so long i mean as much as you're
willing to share how has this increased
attention how have you responded to that
in that sense have you i would imagine
in some ways it can be empowering but i
also imagine that that's a mixed
reaction because i know i've had some of
those reactions myself but how is that
actually
one how have you respond to that and how
has that actually impacted your work as
well as much as you want to share
well
thanks for asking that question um when
we had to start doing food distributions
in the community we decided we would
write another grant
and test out whether or not increasing
food security has an impact on smoking
cessation that grant got funded and
that's part of our
center for research health and social
justice and so we are
asking the question if you intervene on
social factors that we know are
associated with smoking but people
people who are more food insecure more
likely to smoke and less likely to quit
there are studies out there that show
that so if you can intervene on those
factors
does it change circumstances for them
can we get people
out of the addiction cycle
but it's also
forced me to work in the covet arena as
well um
i wasn't running jumping trying to
become involved in reducing disparities
as it
was associated with cove at 19
but the communities in which i was
working were experiencing disparities
in terms of cases in terms of deaths and
in terms of
low vaccine rates i mean we some of our
counties
still have vaccine rates that are in 35
percent
you know and
and so we have a long way to go compared
to vermont and new york
really important
just you know i also just want to
acknowledge again that flexibility and
the fact that you
adjusted to meet people where they were
even though it wasn't your original
research question also knowing that that
takes more work too so i imagine there's
a fine balance
there as well and something i'm sure
we'll come back to in the conversation
kathy also want to give you a chance to
respond to that well starting with your
original question um
you know i have two
i guess personal examples of how
kind of bringing to life what you were
just saying but first of all i need to
say that mitch is a great boss because
he over the course of the pandemic
he allowed me to do a lot of time off
from work
volunteering obviously i took lead but
volunteering because
you mentioned food insecurity
during the pandemic for over a year our
church was asked to help to reach into
the community to deal specifically with
food insecurity and
once we started getting out into the
community i mean it was
you know it was in the midst of the
shutdowns and you know
there were no vaccines and we really
didn't understand where coba was going
to go
but the community need was so
great
and the fear in people's faces were so
great that once we started doing it we
had more and more and more requests and
so basically we would go out into the
community
every day of the week and deliver big
boxes of food and i would always go on
friday mornings and i would see the same
people over and over again
and so many of them deal with so many of
the factors that you were talking about
um but what i'd like to say is it it
gave me
a belief that you know we can band
together in times of intense trial and
we can help others
and so i i felt encouraged by that as
sad as it was to see
and the other
example i would give it was the federal
response to
all the children that were coming in
across the border our southern border
without families and so there was a
massive federal outreach to
go into these cities and help to bring
these children in because once they're
once they step foot in the u.s they're
the
health and human services must take care
for them and so um there was a massive
volunteer unit again which allowed me to
to leave my position for six weeks to go
and um
seeing these children coming across um
it was unbelievable it was sad but it
was also amazing to see how the american
people the the host cities kind of
stepped up to bringing these children
across and and in both cases they were
covered hot zones right it's like
working in the community tons of covid
um and then bringing these kids in and
working in the community to try to help
them find families here
um but yet it gave me a lot of hope that
we are a society that can care about
each other and so not necessarily
related to tobacco control but it's
certainly
i mean you know many of these kids came
across addicted you know many of these
kids had never had
you know even really doctor's
appointments and so it was amazing the
care that we gave them and it
it it really um encouraged me about the
good that we can do
yeah really well said and i love the way
that you all have highlighted just
aspects again of touching on humanity in
different ways some within the work but
some again having that time to be able
to step out of your official role and to
really be able to meet people um where
they are in the midst it sounds like
you've done that a lot of ways even
within the ctp organization so again
just you know themes that you all have
continued to implement in so many
important ways
i'm also curious how
these stories have impacted your
motivation going forward i mean mitch
you touched on that with the the new
normal or what that whatever that might
look like but how is this actually
impacting how you approach things on a
day-to-day basis now in your current
efforts
i i think just you know sort of
programmatically
um
it sort of comes back to
some of the notions i already touched on
um
because
we're working in an administration
that has
in my entire
career in tobacco control going back
um almost 30 years
um i've never seen this kind of focus on
health equity and health disparities
um
i think and this goes way beyond product
regulation this is
an unprecedented opportunity for
comprehensive tobacco control efforts at
all levels federal state and local
and
um it's so it's not directly related to
life in in a pandemic it is directly
related to everything that we are
trying to deal with and struggling as a
society when it comes to
um those who are
more well-off and less well-off and
understanding why
why
why are
entire groups of people in this country
left behind
in our day jobs working on tobacco we
know all of the statistics
that they're they're profound and and
for me
those population level
when we say historically low levels of
of adult and youth smoking that's great
but
who is the remaining smoker and however
you slice and dice it educational
attainment household income is there
what's the smoking status in the
household um racial and ethnic groups um
sexual orientation however you slice it
there are profound disparities when it
comes to tobacco use and so the
opportunity here is finally at the
highest levels attention is being paid
and the for me the fundamental question
is being asked why
even though i think everybody in the
room
can answer that it's
that
deceptively simple questions being asked
in a very very serious way on
as far as i'm concerned inside the
federal government at the highest levels
for the first time
and whether it's tobacco use or food
insecurity or
any other
um
social or public health issue that we
face
i'll share kathy's optimism that
the the the
the s
the sunshine that's being focused on
these issues
is giving us opportunities that we have
not had before the the problems have
always been there
but this is an unprecedented opportunity
because of the attention that they're
getting
really well said
go ahead i think one one thing though um
and not to take the sad side of it but
um
something that's become so clear to me
especially in our work with youth um
is you know the the emerging issues with
mental health and you know our area
what we work most closely with is
obviously trying to prevent use from
using tobacco products but
you know we haven't always been
successful i mean there's been a lot of
um you know countervailing reasons why i
think a lot of kids were especially
started vaping and
now that they're addicted they reach out
to us often and you know with really
incredible stories about how they never
used to be anxious they never used to be
afraid now they feel depressed all the
time now they want it they they
self-isolate themselves and
it really appears that you know on top
of the of the pandemic
we are seeing
many many mental health issues emerge
and you know our piece is just one of it
and um
you know
i always quote this because it was so
telling because one one
team we were talking to in the early
days um and talking about the addiction
and you know he's like you know all i
did was just add crap to the crap and
and i think that there is especially if
you're addicted um you know as you most
you know when you're withdrawing from
that nicotine and you need another hit
it's very anxiety producing but it with
when you add that on top of
everything that was happening with kovid
the fact that everybody was
self-isolated in their homes they
couldn't go out i think that we have a
lot more mental health issues that are
emerging um that are leading to all
sorts of terrible things um
other type of coping mechanisms with
different types of drugs
suicide rates seem incredibly high so i
think you know to me it's it's made me
realize that there's just so much more
that needs to be done
and for me mental health has become a
real big emerging issues that we're
developing messaging on now yeah
yeah really important and i'm glad to
hear that message is being developed but
also seems like the conversation
is being elevated in ways that it wasn't
before yes um and especially even as the
data has come out with all the stressors
that have been added um with kovid i'm
dr figg i also wonder if you would
respond to that just based on the
communities that you've worked in where
obviously stressors can lead to
a lot of these different components both
from mental health side and youth from
you side and how you've
continued to try and approach that even
though there's a lot of work yeah i
think um
the covet 19 and other things that are
happening in the world are forcing us to
think about workforce issues right
and
how do we
retain
a viable workforce
in all sectors how do we
continue to build the scientific
workforce the practitioner workforce
and the advocacy workforce those are
real issues
and um
and also
uh create
new work climates for people to
live breathe and work in that are more
humane
and
still get at productivity and so uh my
experience during cove at 19 is you know
i went home
i took my
desktop home and it was great
and i created more work for myself
because not just because of covet 19 but
you didn't have to run to meetings i
didn't have to travel to work
i saved on that time so i could stop at
lunch time go walk come back and still
be productive
now transitioning back into the
workforce and you've created an extra
four hours of work but now you still
have your four hour
getting ready for work coming home added
on how do we make those adjustments
and people like mitch are retiring
that's his adjustment that's a stressor
that's a stressor look we said we're
going to try to make people laugh
that was a joke
[Laughter]
but um those are real issues and it's a
real mental health issue as well well
i'm trying to make those adjustments
when there's such a great need
but at the same time we have to have
strike a life balance because i'm
getting away from saying work-life
balance it's life balance that's what it
is if you leave with the work part we
get it wrong right it's life balance and
how do we make that happen
and we haven't had enough conversations
about
our transitioning back to
whatever that normal looks like because
it's not what it was yesterday
people kept saying get back to normal i
don't know what that means right now
but we need to have strategic
discussions about what that looks like
and i think we haven't done enough of
that
we have to reframe
what
a research field looks like now
what does an academic workplace look
like what does a federal workplace look
like
that is healthy
mentally healthy viable and productive
and
not contributing to premature deaths
yeah it's been really interesting to see
um just inside of our agency and and i
can and i can say this goes beyond our
center because as a center director i i
hear from leadership throughout fd and
if these 18 000 people
that uh the adaptation to 100
remote or 100 telework once we got
through some technical problems
literally just during the first week was
pretty smooth um and to
pebbles point people got used to it and
actually
um became more productive to the point
where that raised issues of
um
actually work being piled on because
they didn't have to do the commuting and
they didn't and then have all the other
things that come with that and so
where fda as an organization finds
itself now is
asking some really profound questions
about
its physical footprint going forward
doesn't does an agency
like fda need all of those buildings
um or
in whatever the new normal is is it
going to be
you know so different
that that rethinking
the the need for physical workspace or
how much of it
um is something that is starting to be
discussed and it will be very very
interesting to see and assuming those
conversations are happening in other
small medium and large size
organizations
i don't think we can predict what the
future is going to look like other than
it's going to be very very different
from what it looked like for us when it
comes to workplace issues that pebbles
was talking about when it all settles
down i think it's going to be really
different and i think
i hope a much better balance between
work responsibilities making it easier
on
the people who are doing the work while
balancing familial responsibilities as
well
yeah i think that's really important
that you both highlighted that there is
a danger to try to go back to what was
normal before
in the sense that
we don't want to lose everything that
we've learned over the last couple years
things that have been ignored before
that now have more attention
and so that
in itself i think is even attention
for some because there can be this
tendency to try and want to return to
what was normal with all the
caveats that come with that as well
so maybe more so for for kathy and dr
figgy i'm curious
from your standpoints just in the work
that you do and in the communication
space how you think it is important for
us to continue to move things forward so
this doesn't become
passing in a sense because there is i do
often sense that pull for people to just
trying to go back to what felt familiar
even though there were a lot of
problematic aspects with what was
familiar
so how does that
come up i guess in a day-to-day basis
for each of you
well i think especially for
the office that i oversee i think people
have learned to love
the the ability to work exclusively from
home and so if anything
i think
you know what i'm hopeful about is the
opportunity to explore
what a hybrid workspace might look like
and
you know maybe that means that for
really important times of collaboration
people are able to come together but you
know i think that we've learned that
people can be
can do their job and do it really well
um and not be in a physical environment
where you're all together so for me i
think the challenge is going to be
finding that right mix because right now
everybody has i guess what i would call
somewhat of a taste of freedom right so
um and and we really haven't missed a
beat as mitch said multiple times in
terms of productivity and being able to
do our jobs it's like you know we
we um
our bread and butter is talking to the
audiences that we're trying to develop
messaging for and in the early days we
had to really like figure out how we're
going to do that but now we've figured
it out right it's like it's all done
online and we really haven't
had an interruption in our ability to
actually
deeply have a good conversation with a
youth or an adult and so we don't need
to go back to traveling to 28 cities for
48 focus groups right like we know we
can do it online and so i think we've
learned to adapt and i think we're super
productive and i think people love the
opportunity to only dress from here up
and not worry about what's down below
and you know walk into the kitchen and
make lunch or walk and have a nice
afternoon walk and and so i think for me
it's trying to find the right balance
where there's the opportunity because i
i also worry about especially those who
are younger who really would benefit
from the opportunity to listen in
meetings see how things happen see how
like creative brainstorming's go and i
and i do worry that some of the younger
generation
if they if they're not able to be in
person when lightning strikes if
i do think something is lost over zoom
and so
my my worries are how do you keep an
engaged workforce such that they still
feel like they have balance in their
life but that you can continue to grow
and thrive in somewhat of a shared space
but not all the time
yeah
ongoing juggling yeah i mean i would
love to see more strategic discussions
about what the new workplace looks like
i have talked with my team
[Music]
they're all here at the meeting with me
um
and
for their for career development to give
them a break as well come to baltimore
you know see what i what we do here
um but
we've had discussions about
you know how do we move to a four-day
work week
um now that's a tough thing to figure
out places like finland and other
countries have it figured out and the
research is fairly solid on the fact
that you know those countries that have
moved to that particular model that the
people are as productive or more
productive
and so
we have to think very carefully about
that you know the us is very slow to
adopt some of these models that work in
other places and these countries other
countries are doing just fine
they're doing just fine
so we have to reevaluate our value
system
around life
itself
um and i don't think reevaluating it
means that we're giving up something in
terms of making progress because the
reevaluation may help us get
closer to progress faster
and expeditiously right
as compared to the way that we're
we have been doing things so when i said
you know we have to look at
these tragedies as opportunities
sometimes you know because if you you
know the tragedy is the tragedy and if
you let it
um
take you down with mental health issues
you'll
you'll you know destroy yourself so you
have to start looking at things as
opportunities and
what can we do strategically
around the nation
to begin to plan and i think the people
in this room are
primed to do that
around changing
work climate
you know eliminating things such as
microaggression eliminating things such
as biases eliminating things such as
structural racism the academic system
the federal government
doing things like making sure that women
who are concentrated in particular jobs
are paid fair wages and making sure that
women who do community-based work who
are out there busting their butts
get paid the same wages of the person
who's working in the laboratory i mean
we have to think differently
about how we're going to move forward
but it takes
willingness to engage in strategic
discussions around that
in the same way that
private industry has done and say hey
what are we going to do differently
let's look at the workplace
let's look at the goals that we're
trying to accomplish in tobacco
prevention and control how do we get
there and how do we shape the workplace
to
get to that goal without um
killing ourselves
and without contributing to the
premature
morbidity and mortality
by killing the workforce
yeah so i mean those are real issues
yeah
yeah i definitely agree i mean there's
so many great things to to unpack there
to kathy's point from before though i
mean just in a humorous way the uh only
dressing from the top of you all will
notice that we decided and made a pact
that we were going to do the full dress
today so no one came in pajama bottoms
even though i'm sure that was a
temptation just how things have been
going in the past
but dr fagan so many so many key things
which you talked about
one i mean not too complicated but yes
to complicate it in a sense too as
you've mentioned in other settings those
who are doing health disparities
research were often spread thin
in the first place and so that was and
has been the norm now you add on this
layer of also trying to adjust and make
sure that there is balance in
the work day and workforce how do you
and you start to talk about how do you
put those
together i mean i guess the strategic
piece is part of that but there may not
be an easy answer but i just want to at
least kind of highlight that because i
know it's something oh my goodness
i just had this conversation about two
hours ago
um
sometimes you know i think it's helpful
for us to
vocalize some honest things which is
sometimes you just have to check out
right
and take a break
and if that means you may not respond to
an email
ever
doesn't mean that you don't want to
respond to it but sometimes you got to
save yourself right
sometimes it means uh
and i'll give this example two fridays
ago
my um my team
had a tough day
and
i wanted to take them out
so that we could you know we were
supposed to do
a luncheon for and uh celebrating
employee day and
and i said oh to this afternoon let's go
out they were like nope no way
we need to we need a break today
and uh you have to honor that right and
so sometimes you have to check out
sometimes you have to
schedule breaks
you have to do it for yourself and for
the people who are working on your
projects sometimes you have to allow
that sometimes you have to facilitate
that as well sometimes you have to say
today
you know
everybody leave you know we're done
today
sometimes they tell me we're done today
and and when they say that i'm i'm okay
with that so you have to
you know even as a manager of people
you have to be attending to folks needs
sometimes you're trying to save yourself
but you also have to make sure that
you're helping them as well in this
complicated environment but doing health
disparities research i mean you know
those of us who have been doing it for
you know decades um
have
i i say bear the burden of doing the
research and people who are new to it
um
may not hang in there as long because
you really have to be resilient
there's a high level not a low level
very high level of resiliency that you
have to have
in order to survive it because the need
is so great just like i mentioned
earlier you know i've been working in
tobacco disparities i also do
cancer disparities with colorectal
cancer and then covet got added on
and so it's a lot it's a lot um but
there's a great need out there
and
but what brings joy
um
to that
is to see that you are
making a difference that you're
changing someone's life and i don't mean
looking at the survey data i'm talking
about looking at people's faces and
talking to them on the phone
and my team coming back to me saying hey
such and such really um appreciated what
we did
that
makes the difference and that keeps you
going every day
yeah really important and
grounding in a lot of ways as well
despite the
all the effort and resilience that has
to be there to to maintain so in a lot
of ways i think again just giving honor
or honors due for someone like you has
been so deeply engaged in this work for
so long and knowing that it's making
that impact is very encouraging
so i know it's not easy
mitch to uh to pivot back to you as well
on that note as someone who is
shifting into uh retirement just
again curious to hear a little bit about
what motivated you to get into the work
in the first place um and what your i
guess your greatest um
point of achievement and and
gratification has been
you know with this this long and
impactful career
well my um
other than knowing that i wanted to be a
lawyer and did not want to work for a
law firm and did not want to work for a
corporation i just wanted to do public
interest law the my career has been
completely serendipitous
um
and it all started with the first job
that i had out of law school that uh
that you mentioned working for the
center for science and the public
interest
but honestly if my first job out of law
school had been working for a civil
rights organization or an environmental
group or
a
prisoner rights group i think my career
path would have been completely
different but that first job was working
on food labeling food safety and
nutrition
for six years and i did litigation i did
lobbying i did a lot of media work um
and a lot of interactions with fda
and
it's this summer would have been 40
years of my working on fda related
issues but it was
really happenstance
um once i was kind of put on that path
and realized
the work that the food and drug
administration does whether i'm there um
trying to to
advance policy or on the outside trying
to influence policy
um was something that i was very
interested in
the tobacco work for me started in 1994
because the commissioner at the time
david kessler said
we need to investigate the tobacco
industry
we need to truly understand what they
know about the role of nicotine in the
design and manufacture of cigarettes and
smokeless tobacco products e-cigarettes
didn't exist then
and smokeless tobacco was the poster
child for harm reduction back in
the 1990s
um and
it just all happened
um after that
and it was dr kessler who gave me the
opportunity to work on
tobacco and as you all know if you're
here
um
you start working on this whatever your
day job is and uh there's kind of a
different
notion of addiction to the issues
um i i'm i'm retiring but the last 28
years of of my fda-related career it's
been a labor of love with all of the
challenges and with all the ups and
downs um it's been an absolute labor of
love and i couldn't have planned it
like i said it really was
um a serendipitous from that that very
first uh job right after i graduated law
school
i know a lot of people are thankful for
that serendipity for the effort that you
put in over the years so i appreciate
you sharing that as well
as we're getting close to our time i did
want to pivot to some of the public
engagement a bit as well
obviously you know kathy that's your
official job but in a lot of ways a lot
of all of you are involved in public
engagement in some shape or form but
kathy just to
pivot to you again just to talk a little
bit about that within this realm of the
disparities because i know that's been a
big point of emphasis and intentional so
can you talk a little bit about how that
came about and what you've tried to do
within that space even as you're trying
to reach broad audiences at the same
time sure so
um no matter what the issue is and and
you mentioned my my time at the ag
council we oversaw almost 30 different
pieces of business for federal agencies
and
but what was the tie that that bound all
of them together was that you know we
were trying to help people understand
whatever the issue was so that they
could potentially lead
healthier
safer
[Music]
you know more empowered lives and so you
know for me whatever the issue is you
have to understand which audiences
are would most benefit from whatever the
issue is or which audiences are most um
you know disproportionately hurt by
whatever the issue is and then
you know my my suggestion is that
we don't you don't treat the audience as
their homogeneous you really have to
understand like in the case of of youth
who were the youth that were smoking
cigarettes and when you really peel back
the layer of the onion through
comprehensive research you understand
that a picture emerges of those who are
most at risk and then you have to
understand why
what made american indian alaska native
uh teens so at risk what makes african
american youth so at risk for this
product and and and if you treat them as
individuals not as a mass population
and you peel back the layer of the onion
to understand what their current
knowledge is what their attitudes what
their beliefs are what their barriers
are that are you know making them do the
behavior or conversely making them stop
the behavior you can begin to develop
messaging that will be
relevant and persuasive but based on the
uniqueness of that individual and so
to me um
it's about what the issue is who is most
hurt by the issue what can you learn
about them what do you how far do you
need to nudge them to really help them
um and and that's how we approach all of
our advertising efforts
yeah that's really encouraging here just
that attitude of really listening and
meeting people where they're at in the
in the programs that you're putting
together and it seems like it's been
very effective from the statistics i've
heard you share over the years as well
um dr fagan and mitch i wonder if you'd
comment on what how you've also i mean
dr pham also just thinking about all the
different things you do and the
different
layers of your communication in
different communities and how you've
navigated that over the years as well
yeah i want to talk about state
legislatures you know because when i
came out of the federal government and
started working
in academia i had to
figure out how to communicate issues
around tobacco to state legislators in
hawaii and then do it in arkansas which
are two very different states and how
you communicate that information you
know while in hawaii
the big issue that we were dealing with
at the time was
e-cigarettes took off there um early
compared to other states because their
cigarette smoking rates were down
because the taxes were so high
um but e-cigarettes shot up
and so we were our research team there
started working on e-cigarettes early on
and we had some of the first papers to
come out
looking at the association between
e-cigarettes and quitting behaviors um
paula pogrell was the lead author on
that paper back in 2013
but we had to learn how to communicate
issues to state legislators who were
unfamiliar with products who were
unfamiliar with issues around flavors
who weren't necessarily familiar with
issues related to menthol
you know as a flavor
and so um i had to become skilled at
that
and then i went to arkansas
where
you have a different group of state
legislators who are very
pro-tobacco
um hawaii was anti-tobacco but there's
still a skill set that you had to
develop to communicate things to them
and so it's a work in progress learning
how to influence policies
at the state level
educating people about the things that
need to be done to protect youth from
e-cigarettes to
help people to get
help with quitting tobacco products to
make sure that
just disparate communities have access
to nicotine replacement therapy when
they call the quit line they can access
those things and so i think we still
have a long ways to go in terms of
sharing
stories
across states
on how you
communicate things to state legislators
to make sure that we are improving
public health and not harming public
health really well said i i think i
think for me and listening to what kathy
and pebbles were saying the
the thing that resonated with me as i
think about
the the job that i've had for the last
nine years but
having learned from each previous
position and the the people i've had the
privilege of working for throughout my
career
it really comes down to it sounds simple
but it's actually really hard understand
your audience that's what i was hearing
from kathy and pebbles and when you
think you're you understand your
audience think again
um because if you if you think again
you may come up with something else that
you hadn't thought of before and in my
job whether it's
inside of government and having to
engage with
members of congress staff
whoever the incumbent administration is
at the department level or at the white
house
or or whether it's with any of the
stakeholders
that that we have a responsibility to
engage with or media advocacy
understand where
your audience is coming from what's on
their mind
whether it's
something that you see as things they
don't understand that they need to
better understand or if they're a
decision maker something that you're
trying to persuade them to to agree to
but understanding where they're coming
from and what might be holding them back
and
we spend a lot of our time trying to
understand our our various audiences and
the more effort we put in
to that in in any setting in any
encounter it doesn't doesn't
dramatically raise the likelihood of
success but it makes for a much more
productive um interaction and
and
even when we deal with tobacco companies
there's a need for a dialogue and
there's a need for you know a degree of
mutual understanding even if at the end
of the day there's way more that you
might disagree with than agree with but
just the responsibility to understand
your audience yeah again that really
ties back into that
level of humanity as well as you all
have been highlighting in your comments
maybe not necessarily with that word but
i just that sense has been coming out as
well i think it's really really
important
well as we get ready to close i'd just
also like to give you all an opportunity
to you know kind of have a final message
to our in-person listeners and to those
who are listening
on all the audio platforms what
so both in terms of what gives you
encouragement which you all talked about
and hope moving forward and just uh any
words of uh guidance that you'd like to
share just with the general audience as
well around these aspects that we've
highlighted today so well end up it's a
light question not necessarily but kathy
you look like you're ready so
i think um one thing i would love to to
share is that you know
nicotine is obviously an incredibly
addictive drug but what i have seen is
tremendous success
in
both preventing youth from using the
product by finding
ways in that are meaningful to them to
help them just to make a different
decision before they ever try tobacco
product
and despite the fact that how addictive
it is i'm very encouraged that
we know that kids once they are addicted
are very very open to getting help and
you know at the federal level the most i
can do with the advertising that we
develop is help them to
convince them to
take an opportunity to quit but there
are so many amazing services that if i
can open the door to that and then hand
them over
to for instance nci which which really
helps in a collaborative way to give
them the tools and the
techniques that they need to quit so i
guess my my my overall point is is that
if you're in a communications and
messaging field um if you find the right
insight to the right audience and you
have the right creative wrapper you
really can break through um and and help
them live healthier lives
really well said thanks so much dr fagan
yeah there are two two things i want to
leave the audience with which is uh
uh i'm very excited about um
our
developing new bold leadership in the
field
and not just in tobacco prevention and
control but public health and all of the
sciences because
you know if we're looking at it from a
multi-transdisciplinary approach we need
each other
in order to
really reduce the total tobacco use in
this country
and so um
you know i'm asking that
the next generation of people
get engaged in leadership opportunities
to grow to develop
and take both steps take risks
you have nothing to lose
i can assure you of that
and when you think you have something to
lose talk to a
senior person about if that loss
that you think you have to lose by
taking various risk
is a real loss or is there something to
be gained by that risk that you may take
i've taken risk all of my life
and it hasn't necessarily been pretty
all of the time
but um i get i'm still here on the stage
with these wonderful people my
colleagues here
and life goes on even when you take
those risks when you don't take the risk
you risk the chance of nothing happening
around you
that's a big risk that nothing changes
around you when you don't take the risk
and the second point i want to make
is that
when it comes to reducing this
disparities in
populations who have historically been
marginalized
for decades and who have suffered from
poverty
combined with segregation combined with
being
depoliticized and all those things that
cause oppression
we don't need those communities on
substances at all
you know
you know and so
uh because they're already poor they're
already in circumstances that continue
to facilitate the addiction cycle
and so those of us who've been working
in disparities research for a long time
don't want our communities on any
substances you know we want the alcohol
stores gone you know we want the tobacco
shops gone
and we need to leave our communities
healthy because they have so many things
stacked against them
and that's
just um you know i know people have
different opinions about it but those of
us who worked in health disparities
research that is kind of the perspective
that we have on that as it comes to
addictive products
thanks for sharing so so honestly and so
boldly and also appreciate your
encouraging words to the upcoming and
rising generation as well really really
well said
mitch
um i think i'll pick up on
pebble's first point about
be bold and take risks i i completely
agree with that but
um
there's
there's a lesson
uh that needs to be
um
top of mind when you do that which is
the the bolder you're you're going to be
in in in the field that that we're in
given who and what we are up against
the harder
it is to bring about profound change so
yes
um be bold and take the risks but
have patience
because
the more impactful a potential policy or
a program is
many times the harder it is to see it
put into place so don't give up
and have patience in
in 1994 when i started working on
tobacco
um fda went to the world conference on
tobacco and health for the very first
time and i was one of the
the two fdars that got on a plane flew
to paris where there was a smoking
section on the plane and we were sitting
in the last row of the non-smoking
section so a lot of good that did on an
overnight flight with the smoking
section right behind us and and here we
were
we were going to tear down walls with
product regulation in 1994 we're going
to the world conference and someone said
you need to go here nigel gray
nigel gray has been um who who nigel
who's no longer with us but who uh
global leader in the field and very
prominent member of srt for many many
years
they said you need to go hear nigel grey
talk and i went to nigel's talk in 1994.
guns ablazon and and nigel said what we
do is so hard that he he was trying to
teach lessons to those of us new to
tobacco control at that time and and his
message was
um
the yardstick by which we need to
measure success or failure because of
what we do is so hard is by the decade
10-year increments
before you know whether you have
succeeded or failed on on the big stuff
not on the small stuff
and i was sitting there having none of
it
because we were going to
tear down walls you know really quickly
and and
and bring about this
profound change but he was right
he was right and so that's how i would
would sync up everything that that i've
had the privilege of working on in my
career with what pebbles was saying
about
being bold and taking risks that that's
how we get change made but make sure you
have the patience and the intestinal
fortitude um
and the dedication and the spirit that i
know everybody in this room and
everybody listening to this podcast does
because the more impactful the change
the harder it is to see that change
happen
[Music]
thanks for sharing sharing that story as
well on that perspective but one thing i
just want to also add to everything you
all have said is just the importance of
community as well because one thing that
jumps out to me is the work that you all
do
even as you are invested
in these other communities as well so i
mean that story touches on that dr fagan
what you've mentioned is also
touches on that and and also uh kathy
what you've mentioned as well so again i
know i'm pointing my mental health
component but that's so important for us
to be able to be engaged in community
especially
in this work where we're wanting to see
these changes so that we're able to
support one another
and not get to a point where we're
running a thousand miles an hour and no
longer able to continue the work
so just wanted to mention that as well
again just an honor to be able to have
all of you here for this in-person
recording for those
who are listing that also encourage you
to look up these individuals just to
learn about the impact and the efforts
that they've made and will continue to
make mitch i have a feeling that your
legacy will continue even when you're no
longer officially in the role maybe
there'll be some way you'll also
continue to be contributing
as i know many who step into retirement
often find themselves doing i'll just
put it that way so
and thanks to everyone who's been here
in person for this live recording it's
been an honor hosting it and hope that
you all
really enjoyed the conversation the way
we're able to peel back some of the
layers so to speak as well thanks again
to all of you for joining great thank
you
awesome
[Music]